à
donc je vous reviens venu pour le 7-8
l'actu en ce vendredi 6 décembre nous
faisons le tour de l'actualité locale de
la journée nous allons aussi revenir sur
les principaux événements de cette
semaine voici sans plus attendre les
titres le téléthon c'est parti jusqu'à
samedi soir de nombreuses opérations
dans les yvelines afin de récolter des
fonds contre les maladies rares et
permettre aux chercheurs du généthon
d'avancé un drive dédié aux produits
laitiers c'est à la ferme de grignon le
service est proposé depuis cette semaine
dominique tristan le directeur du site
va nous en parler dans quelques instants
et puis elle amusée de la toile de jouy
a réouvert ses portes à jouy en josas de
vastes travaux viennent de se dérouler
le public qui peut accéder à nouveau à
ce site et redécouvrir les collections
abrité depuis 1991 dans le château 19e
siècle de l'églantine l image du jour
c'est ce but ce qui va sillonner les
rues de saint quentin en yvelines afin
de collecter jouets neufs ou en bon état
pour aider le père noël dans sa
distribution aux plus défavorisés
la société ski bus relance l'opération
bus de noël à partir du 9 décembre dès
lundi est depuis 1996 la collecte est
suivie d'une distribution par les
associations humanitaires
plus de quinze mille jouets distribuer
les années précédentes vous pouvez à
noter les escales des 11 et 14 décembre
de 10 à 18 heures rue le nôtre au centre
commercial espace saint quentin
je reçois donc pour cette édition du 7 8
l'aktu domine tristan bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes directeur de la ferme degré
dion ferme expérimentale rattachée à
l'école agroparistech qui vient
d'inaugurer un drive spécialisé dans les
produits laitiers drive qui a ouvert son
site internet lundi la distribution pour
pouvoir commander les produits auprès de
l'établissement et ensuite les récupérer
ce sera aujourd'hui vendredi
est ce que c'est un succès d'ores et
déjà après une petite semaine mise en
route mais on va dire que c'était un bon
début et que voilà on a des perspectives
assez intéressante sur les semaines à
venir
on sait que le lancer au mois de
novembre ça représente certes un risque
mais on est plutôt satisfait de ce
premier début combien de clients pour
cette première pour l'instant 15
commandes ça correspond ce que vous
aviez prévu voilà c'est à peu près l
ordre de grandeur qu'on s'était fixés au
départ en espérant que ça continue à se
développer assez rapidement alors le
mode de fonctionnement c'est assez
simple si vous êtes habitué des drive
ans il suffit d'aller sur le site
internet
qui va s'afficher d'ailleurs vous faire
passer commande on voit les images de ce
site on passe commande de produits
laitiers et on les récupère le vendredi
sur un site précise aux alentours de la
ferme
voilà ce juste devant la ferme au niveau
du rond-point sur une route assez
passante entre 16 heures et 20 heures
entre 16h et 20h tout à fait alors ce
mode de fonctionnement pourquoi l'avoir
mis en place pourquoi décidez de vendre
les produits qu'on prouvait déjà trouvé
sur le site même de la ferme via le
drive alors tout d'abord on est présent
bien sûr au niveau de la vente dans
notre ferme sur l'autre boutique on est
aussi présent chez des crémiers chez les
fromagers
chez des fermes voisines qui ont aussi
une activité d'accueil une cueillette
par exemple on a aussi pas présent un
tout petit peu en grande surface et on
voit se développer maintenant de plus en
plus chaque secteur drive et on se dit
que ça pourrait aussi être une
opportunité pour nous sachant que comme
je l'avais dit la route est très
passante on a plus de vingt mille
voitures qui passent par jour alors que
voilà
la nécessité d'une demande des clients
ou justement de la boue alors tu as une
demande en tant que tel mais c'est vrai
qu'on a fait une enquête par rapport aux
clients actuels de la boutique on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait plutôt une clientèle
assez âgées quelque part le drive
pouvait être complémentaires puisque
on a de l'expérience en grande surface
un profil de clientèle plutôt à ces
jeunes de gens assez pressé et des
cadres supérieurs qui ont pas le temps
de faire les courses la semaine mais qui
veulent profiter du drive le samedi
matin est bien là au lieu de le faire le
samedi matin en grande surface ils
pourront faire au moins pour une partie
pour les produits boursiers s'est
produit le vendredi soir en rentrant du
travail avec un petit détour au niveau
de notre en point alors pourquoi un
drive laitiers uniquement or pour
l'instant on commence avec nos produits
uniquement produit sur l'exploitation
mais l'idée à terme et bien
effectivement d'augmenter l'offre
l'offre de produits bons la prise de
risque étant quand même assez importante
on a préféré se limiter déjà à nos
produits il a commencé ses met en place
sur le plan technique justement vous
parlez de prise de risque ce n'est pas
aussi facile c'est pas du jour au
lendemain et que vous avez décidé de
monter un site
bon alors il ya déjà la création du site
en tant que tel donc là on est passé par
un prestataire du monde agricole c'est
l'assemblée permanente des chambres et
culture qui a déjà développé ce système
pour d'autres drive en gironde notamment
donc là bon ça a pris quelques temps au
niveau informatique puis ensuite il ya
l'aspect logistique pour préparer les
commandes pour la distribution bon bien
entendu là quand vous imaginez on a
livré 15 15 clients aujourd'hui avec un
panier moyen qui est autour de 12,12
euros c'est pas suffisant pour pouvoir
payer une personne pendant cinq à six
heures pour pour ça donc l'idée c'est
bien d'augmenter les volumes et l'offre
de produits à terme justement sur le
coup ça coûte combien au consommateur
est ce que ça coûte plus cher parce
qu'on s'aligne en fait sur les prix de
notre boutique
d'une part pour être cohérent vis-à-vis
des consommateurs qui est pas d'intérêt
à les langues autres que l'idée ce n'est
pas de concurrencer mais au contraire
d'apporter un service supplémentaire
pour de nouveaux clients qui sont
intéressés par ce système de vente
on va parler de ce système de driver
laitiers que vous avez décidé de mettre
en place et qui fera peut-être des
émules on le verra à travers la france
dans les prochains mois pour l'instant
nous vous avons posé cette question êtes
vous un adepte du drive pour faire vos
courses
voici quelques réponses aussi lieu
d'aller à
emporter entre midi et deux pour manger
ta plus vite mais je trouve que des fois
il ya beaucoup de coups gagnants pas
trop j'ai jamais fait en fait mais
effectivement ça peut être intéressant
on est là pour ça que ma campagne fin ça
peut être intéressant
thai binh c'est bien on va choisir ce
qu'on veut vraiment c'est là que si on
achète un des produits frais on peut pas
choisir sa date de péremption ou ou la
qualité de sa viande se vend pas je n'ai
pas très l'écusson n'ai pas vu j'ai pas
avant je n'ai pas été très bien peu
médiatisé avec le système donc pour
l'instant je ne sors pas mais pourquoi
pas ouais c'est facile un peu utilisé
ces pratiques
ces quelques quelques réponses et encore
des gens à convaincre drive voilà mais
c'est en tout cas le début ce que vous
ce que vous lancez vous êtes les
premiers à vous lancer dans sur ce type
d'opération des drags fermiers saint
édouard iii si je me trompe pas brave
laitiers pendant les premiers
effectivement vous avez pris contact
avec justement ceux qui ont lancé ces
drive fermiers pour voir imposer
nettement un seul un seul
on sait qu'il ya quelques difficultés
quand même aussi au niveau volume bon le
voilà vingt mille voitures qui passent
par jour s'il y en a un pour cent qui
s'arrête le vendredi ça fait déjà deux
sens voilà je me dis qu'un potentiel
important et essayons de le développer
et puis de fidéliser aussi la clientèle
son long terme avec des produits de
qualité wifi 10 et la clientèle et
pourquoi pas la faire venir sur le site
même et non bien sûr c'est le trail
c'est aussi un moyen le drive de faire
connaître la ferme qui se visite toute
l'année gratuitement et donc derrière de
faire un détour par la boutique tout à
fait cette boutique se porte bien
justement se porte bien se porte de
mieux en mieux avec un portefeuille de
produits qui s'élargit des services
autour comme la visite aussi on vient
d'ouvrir une brasserie la semaine
dernière juste à côté donc voilà tout ça
est en train de se développer
je pense qu'on est sur une bonne pente
pour vous ça va forcément marcher c'est
l'avenir du commerce ne serait-ce qu' on
ne pense pas aux grands commerces aux
grandes enseignes mais sur des enseignes
sur des structures comme les vôtres
plutôt celles à venir aussi
le drive seul je sais pas
ce qui part de zéro c'est vrai que
l'investissement est beaucoup moindre
que faire une boutique en dur
ça peut être un début ça peut être un
complément de ce qui existe déjà
donc lui j'y crois je crois c'est pour
ça qu'on y allait d'ailleurs et on va
rappeler donc c'est un drive laitiers
pour l'instant vous pouvez commander vos
produits laitiers mais par la suite
d'autres produits vont faire leur
apparition qu'elle a un petit peu le
calendrier vous vous êtes fixés et puis
on va peut-être appeler les produits
qu'on pourrait à l'avenir trouver alors
assez rapidement notre bière la grille
nyonnaise
du miel aussi son mât des ruches sur le
site de la fondation de la viande en
caissettes d'agneau notamment puis assez
rapidement tous les produits qu'on peut
trouver à la boutique
donc là il ya un panel de 20 s'est
diversifiée on a des charcuteries on a
tout l'unité une gamme de
confitures épicé était rare donc on va
aller rejet race et rapidement merci
d'être venu nous présenter ce concept
donc du drive le laitier que vous avez
lancé cette semaine vous commandez vos
produits sur le site internet voulait
récupérer après une semaine de travail
difficiles le vendredi entre 16h et 20h
merci à vous merci bon accueil on
poursuit donc cette actualité après les
drive vous aurez peut-être d'ailleurs
continuer à faire vos courses le
dimanche les magasins vont rester
ouverts pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
dérogation permanente pour le secteur du
bricolage mais il ya une avancée cette
semaine avec une dérogation le
temporaire avant l'établissement d'une
nouvelle loi
conclusion du rapport de jean paul
bailly l'ancien patron de la poste qui a
été remis au gouvernement au début de
semaine rapport très attendu vous le
savez ce dossier déchaîne les passions
nous avons recueilli la réaction du
collectif des bricoleurs du dimanche qui
pour l'instant semble plutôt satisfait
on écoute 110 l eau par les salariés aux
clayes-sous-bois on voit que le
gouvernement a entendu qu'il nous aime
quand même un décret provisoire
cependant c'est vraiment pas une
victoire puisqu'il faut attendre fait la
loi de 2004 offre qu'il sera vraiment
déçu génère sur le sujet alors
effectivement nous ce qu'on demandait
c'était un décret pour le secteur du
bricolage et nous ne l'avons pas obtenu
cependant
il s'agit dorénavant de voir les
ententes au niveau territorial et au
niveau social
donc au niveau social nous nous avons
tout ce qui va bien puisqu'on a un
salaire majoré un deuxième jour un repos
compensateur et que c'est du volontariat
maintenant il faut voir ce que donneront
les accords territoriaux réellement
puisque ce qui nous intéressait
réellement c'était l'ouverture des
magasins de bricolage en ile de france
et que si c'est si c'est ça que visent
les accords territoriaux ce sera ce sera
ça sera une partie gagnée
la pétition sera toujours en cours
puisque nous n'avons qu'un décret
transitoire et que aujourd'hui on tient
réellement remercier nos clients qu'on
était plus de 300 md à seynod nos
pétitions et le fait qu'on ait ce décret
transitoire c'est quand même une
certaine reconnaissance que l'activité
de bricolage et de nos jours un loisir
et voire même une passion et que c'est
que ça permet aux clients de s'équiper
eux-mêmes et donc du coup si vous voulez
il y aura ça pour la loi et nous on va
continuer d'être d'être présent pour
montrer qu'on veut que la loi ne soit
pas une loi mallié 2 et que ce soit pas
un peu du n'importe quoi même en termes
de concurrence que du coup on soit
complètement perdu quoi voilà pour cette
réaction du collectif à travers donc
cette salariée de bois d'arcy ce
vendredi en mairie de versailles les
jeunes udi vont présenter leurs projets
pour les mois à venir le président à
national sera présent
aurélien 70 des membres de la formation
centriste des yvelines des
hauts-de-seine est de paris sont
attendus à partir de 20h à versailles
les jeunes udi qui éliront leur
président dans les yvelines la semaine
suivante le 14 décembre
jeudi prochain 12 décembre c'est la date
choisie par l'intersyndicale de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines pour appeler à manifester
les syndicats réclament un plus grand
soutien du ministère alors que
l'université accuse un déficit de 4
millions d'euros
une assemblée générale vient de se tenir
catherine zola tôt et patrick jacques de
dixmude
professeurs étudiants personnels réunis
en assemblée générale ils parlent tous
d'une même voix alors que l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin accuse un
déficit de 4 millions d'euros
le ministère a accordé une rallonge
budgétaire a lui vécu mais les économies
décidées inquiète l'intersyndicale ce
qui nous fait peur c'est devoir payer
l'austérité effectivement pendant 20 ans
et que les solutions qu'on nous propose
pour effectivement rattraper ce trou
énorme quand même hein et dont on a pris
connaissance assez tardivement revient
effectivement les conditions d'études
des étudiants se traduise à terme par
des licenciements de personnels
contractuels premièrement s'il ya eu
erreur de gestion et ça c'est évidemment
au ministère de le dire c'est nous qui
toujours qui pouvons le savoir ce n'est
pas une raison pour faire payer aux
étudiants et aux personnels ces heures
de gestion passée deuxièmement ce que
nous voulons dire c'est que au delà des
problèmes de gestion locale 1 de
l'université
il y a quand même un contexte général
investit n'ose pas la seule université à
être en déficit et ne sera pas la seule
reste en déficit ni en 2013 1014 et ça
évidemment là dessus la ministre de
communique beaucoup moins
l'intersyndicale met en cause les
partenariats public privé ils ont été
notamment signé dans le cadre de la
construction de l'ufr des sciences
demandant la dénonciation même pas la
mise à plat la dénonciation puisque ces
partenariats public privé sont
complètement inadaptés à la gestion du
patrimoine
immobiliers publics tout simplement
parce qu'il nous empêche de planifier et
d'avoir les investissements et de
redonner à la puissance publique le
libre choix de ses décisions
l'ensemble des ppp aujourd'hui sont
mauvais pour l'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche
et nous demandons donc à ce que lance le
ministère est de lui vs que
l'association ppp notamment de pvp donc
le pp économies d'énergie et le ppp qui
concerne le bâtiment en médecine aabar
woods parmi ceux qui se sont mobilisés
en faveur de ces partenariats valérie
pécresse ancien ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
l'actuel député des yvelines défense
type de contrat tout en pointant du
doigt le manque de formation des
gestionnaires d'université après si un
partenariat est mal négocié
si un partenariat est mal gérée eh bien
ça peut tourner à la catastrophe
6 mais ce n'est pas l'outil lui-même
qu'il faut condamner ce qu'il faut c'est
en amont bien géré les dossiers et ça
nous remet sur la vraie question qui est
est ce qu'il y a dans l'univers c'est
versailles saint quentin suffisamment de
personnel qualifié et suffisamment de
moyens pour permettre à l'université
d'avoir les motards de pouvoir réaliser
toutes ses ambitions et à cette question
je pense que malheureusement la réponse
aujourd'hui et et non le président de
l'université jean luc vestiaire doit
présenter son budget à la mi décembre en
attendant l'intersyndicale appelle à
manifester le 12 décembre à 10 heures
devant le rectorat inversant les
syndicats d'auto-école mécontents
concernant les attributions des places
d'examen du permis de conduire les
délais sont trop longs et la grève des
inspecteurs qui perdure ne va pas
arranger les choses elle aurait même
plutôt tendance à irriter les
représentants des syndicats dont
l'unique l'union nationale des
indépendants de la conduite qui demande
une privatisation de cet examen et qui
reste gérée aujourd'hui par l'état on
écoute l'une des représentantes du
mouvement invité du journal lundi
dernier ça fait déjà un moment qu'on
demande à ce que ça change il y avait
déjà eu une première phase en 2008 parce
qu'on avait déjà demandé ça
l'été à prier aujourd'hui je souhaitais
s'est privatisé ont fait rêver c'est
notre société qui puisse s'en occuper
bah oui parce que actuellement les
examens sont
le monopole de l'état c'est l'état qui
décide le nombre de places qui va
attribuer deux manières départementales
et régionales
c'est dans chaque région c'est comme ça
et puis bah du coup ça ça bloque puisque
il suffit qu'ils aient des inspecteurs
malades en vacances ça donc les
coefficient diminue diminue diminuent
comme peau de chagrin
on nous a annoncé cette année au mois de
novembre que nous allions être touchées
par la diminution des effectifs
les fonctionnaires donc en 2014 on va
encore perdre des inspecteurs cette
situation a également une incidence sur
la situation financière de vos
entreprises de vaud auto école pour vous
par exemple sur sur but
eh ben on
on a
on est comme tout le monde à ont subi la
crise ce qu'on ait des entreprises au
même titre que n'importe quelle
entreprise
ça fait dix ans - que les airs c'est la
première fois que j'entends par lang
licenciements dans notre métier
et là on a vraiment bain des diminutions
d'effectifs flagrant parce que bon on
peut pas se développer
cellier puisque en tout cas en partie au
fait de ne pas pouvoir inscrire
rapidement les acteurs dida qui veut
passer rapidement son permis c'est pas
toujours évident donc il va suspendre où
il va retarder sa formation donc
forcément on peut pas on peut pas
développer nos activités c'est pas
possible
l'actualité c'est aussi une sordide
affaire d'infanticide dans les yvelines
et ses dernières informations délivrées
ce vendredi midi par le procureur de la
république de versailles bonjour anthony
vous étiez présent lors de cette
conférence de presse de dernière minute
on va déjà redonné le cadre de cette
affaire
wilfrid tout commence le 29 novembre
dernier une femme à peu près de 43 ans
habitant la queue-lez-yvelines appelle
le samu est dit souffrir de graves
pertes gynécologique
alors l'enfant de l'ambulance l'emmène
tout de suite vers l'hôpital mignot et
là les médecins s'aperçoivent a très
vite en fait qu'il ya eu un accouchement
quelques jours auparavant
de son côté la femme indique qu'elle n'a
été enregistré à l'hôpital de trappes
pourtant dans cet établissement aucune
aucun enregistrement aucune trace de cet
accouchement n'a été notifié tout de
suite le douteux survie en fin de compte
sur l'honnêteté de cette femme c'est
heavy noise le parquet de versailles est
saisie de la faire il envoie tout de
suite une patrouille de gendarmes à la
queue-lez-yvelines sur place les
gendarmes trouvent un nourrisson mort
dans un double sac plastique
après examen psychiatrique de la jeune
femme
cet examen les faits révèle tout
simplement qu'elle est elle est instable
psychologiquement elle est placée donc
en garde à vue le procureur a insisté un
chevreuil et aspect là lors de sa
conférence de presse aujourd'hui
vendredi sur cette instabilité sur ce
profil particulier de cette femme oui
injuste l'autopsié révèle a révélé il ya
quelques jours qu en fait la petite
fille serait né viable
c'est une petite fille a priori selon
les premières informations et elle
serait née le 27 novembre soit deux
jours
avant l'appel vers le samu est
probablement morte étouffée vous lisiez
donc sur ce profil psychologique elle
serait instable
pourtant aucun dans tes sens jeudi au
d'aucun antécédent pardon judiciaire une
assistante de direction à ces communes
avec une situation très stable un
appartement très correct mais déjà mère
de deux enfants peuvent en 2004 mais les
deux enfants qu'elle avait qui sont donc
majeurs à l'heure actuelle ne vivent pas
avec elle elle a plusieurs amants dont
l'un serait le père de l'enfant retrouvé
étouffé et on évoque des précédents dans
cette affaire aujourd'hui il y aura eu
un autre cas similaire
oui cette personne qui apparaît très
froide sans empathie auprès des
enquêteurs auraient déjà fait part d'une
affaire similaire
un autre enfant dont elle aurait
accouché en 2005
ce serait peut-être un garçon n'est pas
encore sûr déclarés à l'état civil
pourtant une semaine plus tard aucune
trace on ne le retrouve plus nulle part
merci anthony de ces précisions nous
reviendrons sur cette affaire
d'infanticides dans les yvelines la
queue-lez-yvelines c'était fin novembre
nous en parlerons à dès lundi le
téléthon en 2013 et lancer des
animations dans tout le département avec
un village d'accueil centralisateur à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse l'argent
collecté au profit de l'afm est reversée
en très grande partie au profit du
généthon le laboratoire de recherche
installé à evry et nous a ouvert ses
portes alors que les essais se
poursuivent
les premiers médicaments pourraient être
commercialisés dès 2010 est un
laboratoire de recherche financé à 90%
par des dons de particuliers c'est
unique et c'est le généthon créé en 1990
grâce aux dons du téléthon pour lutter
contre les maladies rares ce sont
aujourd'hui 230 experts qui conçoivent
développent et produisent et thérapies
pour traiter les maladies génétiques
rares
ces thérapies intéresse peu l'industrie
pharmaceutique
et pourtant cela sert à tous des
maladies rares ces trois millions de
personnes en france alors c'est
évidemment chacune de ces maladies
touchent un nombre limité de personnes
mais au global c'est trois millions de
personnes touchées en france par une
maladie rend 30 millions de personnes
touchées par une maladie rare en europe
donc un véritable problème de santé
publique et en même temps les
innovations thérapeutiques qui sont les
innovations thérapeutiques de pointe
qu'on fait ici dans le maine de la
thérapie génique par exemple ses
émotions thérapeutiques de pointe
serviront également pour les maladies
fréquentes
quand on travaille sur une maladie rare
du système nerveux et bien évidemment ce
qu'on développe là pourra servir pour
des maladies plus fréquentes du système
nerveux maladies neurodégénératives m'a
dit parkinson maladie d'alzheimer dans
cette banque d'adr par exemple en
collecte les prélèvements de famille
atteinte de maladie génétique on en
extrait la matière première pour la
mettre à la disposition de la recherche
et grâce aux dons du téléthon tout est
allé assez vite dit on a vraiment permis
de développer des outils thérapeutiques
que l'on a testé dans un premier temps
chez des souris pour le petit animal et
maintenant généthon on est vraiment au
stade des essais chez l'homme
et ça c'est vraiment la grande grande
première aujourd'hui le fait d'être au
stade des essais chez l'homme de
produire tant des plus grandes quantités
ses médicaments expérimentaux
c'est vraiment le but que nous étions
fixés même si le but ultime ce sera
vraiment la mise sur le marché le plus
largement pour pour les patients mais
c'est vraiment pour nous un changement
de dimension en changement d'échelle et
le résultat de 2 25 années d'espoir la
mise à disposition des médicaments pour
les patients ce sera pour 2010 aide pour
ce faire j'ai dit ont évolué de
laboratoires de recherche associatif à
but non lucratif il vient d'obtenir le
statut d'établissement pharmaceutique
ce qui va permettre au laboratoire de
produire lui même demain les médicaments
espérer c'est dire si le programme a
toujours besoin de plus de financement
et attend donc beaucoup de cette
nouvelle édition du téléthon objectifs
au niveau national battre les 81
millions d'euros collectés l'an dernier
surtout endiguer la diminution de 5% de
cette collecte de l'an dernier des
promesses de dons la troisième édition
des rencontres de l'autonomie on reste
dans le domaine de la santé se dérouler
du 3 au 5 décembre à saint quentin en
yvelines
avec plus d'un million de bénéficiaires
de l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie en 2012 le sujet
représentent un enjeu majeur pour le
gouvernement rodolphe du moulin c'est le
représentant de la ministre il est
délégué de la ministre chargée des
personnes âgées de l'autonomie il s'est
déplacé sur les lieux du lancement de
l'opération à la faculté des sciences de
la santé à montigny le bretonneux
retour sur cette visite avec violaine
thorez patrick jacques de dixmude
également pour les images la troisième
édition des rencontres de l'autonomie a
débuté mardi michèle delaunay ministre
délégué chargé des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie finalement représenté par
son conseiller
rodolphe du moulin l'occasion pour lui
d'annoncer les grandes lignes du projet
de loi du gouvernement dans le domaine
la concertation a été lancée vendredi
dernier le plan devrait entrer en
vigueur en 2015
d'après les chiffres du gouvernement les
plus de 60 ans représentent aujourd'hui
à peu près 25% de la population
demain ils seraient plus d'un tiers
c'est un projet qui intégrera la réforme
de la dépendance celle qu'avait été tant
de fois promise et reportée
c'est à dire la réforme de l'aide
personnalisée autonomie mais aussi un
volet prévention de la perte d'autonomie
qui cherchera à identifier comment on
peut mieux anticiper les pertes
d'autonomie car on y peut quelque chose
notamment par les aides techniques par
les actions de prévention
et puis un volet adaptation de la
société vieillissement les rencontres de
l'autonomie se sont poursuivies sur
trois jours avec des ateliers grand
public proposé sur le site de gérer
handicap à magny les hameaux pour
évoquer la protection juridique la loi
léonetti et le bien-être
on termine par cette information le
musée de la toile de jouy c'était à jouy
en josas a été totalement rénové après à
six mois de chantier les nouveaux
intérieurs ont été présentés ce jeudi
soir le musée qui abrite depuis 1991
dans le château de l'églantine ses
collections était fermé au public depuis
la mi juillet
les travaux ont permis de tout repenser
notamment les éclairages des vitrines
plus adapté pour ne pas abîmer les
toiles de coton très fragile certaines
de ses toiles ont plus de 200 ans les
collections permanentes ont été
renouvelés le seront régulièrement tous
les six mois
pour compléter cette modernisation une
application pour tablette est aussi
disponible en français et en anglais le
musée de la toile de jouy rend hommage
au créateur du textile oberkampf qui
avait créé cette manufacture à la fin du
xviiie siècle manufacture qui a employé
jusqu'à mille trois cents ouvriers on
écoute la conservatrice du musée à
présent elle nous parle du père quand il
invente ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
toile de jouy c'est à dire ces grands
textile imprimés de seine ne pastorale
monochrome sur fond du tissu blanc ça
c'est vraiment lui qui l'a inventé et
puis après ces motifs ont été copiés par
d'autres centres dédiés nage en france
mais c'est vraiment lui qui l'a inventé
et il a toujours aussi pour toutes ces
toiles exiger une qualité telles que le
nom toile de jouy est devenu le terme
générique pour ses toiles là est-ce que
oberkampf à par rapport aux autres c'est
que il a toujours été à la pointe des
inventions à la fois techniques
chimiques et artistique qui suivait le
progrès du goût est il adapté toujours
ses toiles à la fois aux événements
historiques mais aussi au goût des arts
décoratifs du temps qui savait tout
faire
il savait c'est un coloriste c'était un
graveur cd gravés ces planches
c'était un dessinateur il a créé ses
premiers modèles tout seul un chef
d'entreprise un entrepreneur vraiment y
cumuler toutes les qualités
c'est grâce à ça qu'il a fait de son
entreprise la troisième entreprise en
fait de france à l'époque
le journal revient à lundi en direct dès
18 heures le week end et n'oubliez pas
le 36 37 pour le téléthon
c'est